tyler perry i don't know a lot about him
but i know that he's a baller
yeah and he's incredibly talented
so what's cool about tyler perry is like
one he's a billionaire but
i mean not a ton of people are
billionaires but like
he is i think an unexpected billionaire
in the sense that
some people haven't even heard his name
right and there's a lot more people who
you would think are
more well known who at least at first
glance have done more things but he's
done a ton of things but just to compare
you're like okay a billion dollars like
he works in you know
in the
uh
movie tv slash um
play industry so like okay that doesn't
sound so crazy but like taylor swift
guess what her net worth was i pulled
this earlier this year so it's probably
way higher but maybe what 50.
so 365 million
leo dicaprio how much do you think his
net worth is 100
260 serena williams
uh is serena the oldest or the youngest
she's the
uh she's the younger one venus is the
oldest 200
yeah so 225. anyway i should share the
weight but one of those what are those
uh what's that source
i don't know i mean some some site on
google so yeah take it with a grain of
salt dude those sites are if
you google like i i tested this if you
google a couple people's net worth some
of my personal websites come up number
one and i just made this up and
i've seen people cite it
well yeah i mean definitely take it with
a grain of salt because i've definitely
googled some of this stuff before and
you'll see someone and one site will be
like their net worth is like 50k in
another site it'll be like their net
worth is 50 million so it's it
definitely you know can vary but the
point is i've through the podcast i've
met one or two like celebrities who if
you google they'll be like yeah they're
worth 10 or 15 and i've talked to them
they're like i wish they're like i got
they're like i make like 100 000 a year
yeah okay so
tyler perry is like at least i think he
was like written about by several
different publications i think they
verified he's a billionaire i believe
with him with him i believe it because
he's on the forbes list
yes exactly so
for that for that reason
his story is awesome because he
basically i mean he didn't start out
with much so he used to when he was
younger he used to watch his dad's
subcontract and his dad would make 800
bucks and the person who he's
contracting for with like net 80 000 and
he remembers thinking at the time like i
always knew there was more power in the
man that owned the house rather than the
man working on building it so i wanted
to be the guy who owned the house so he
like very early on understood the
principle and the importance of
ownership and he had he had a messed up
childhood i think he was molested a
little bit i think his dad was abusive
this guy went through a lot
yeah and he was also a high school
dropout so when he dropped out of high
school he was
you know he was doing a bunch of
different odd jobs he struggled to pay
rent he was a bill collector he sold
cars like he did all types of stuff um
but eventually he saved up enough which
was 12k to rent an atlanta community
theater so this was his first bet he
basically wrote this play himself it was
called i know i've been changed and he
started running this play and you're
probably thinking like oh okay overnight
success no it was really bad at first
and he struggled to pay rent and um
he actually worked on this play for over
a decade he produced the play he sold
the tickets he designed the set he sold
the snacks so he was like doing the
whole thing because no one else would
invest in him at the time but over that
decade i think the play got better he
like reigned in his chops and basically
throughout that decade period he sold
over 100 million in theater tickets 20
million in merch and 30 million in just
the videos of the plays because again he
owned the ip so he can actually make
money
he was just making plays like like
interesting plays and which sounds
simple but that's like and it's hard
crazy so he made these wonderful plays
and was it like he made a bunch and then
they went to different and they like did
he like literally tour and just make
like 50 grand a night through um like
hosting it in atlanta and then nashville
and then like chicago or wherever
i think that it was just this one play i
know i've been changed but i do think
that they did like several tours and
actually one of the one of the different
theaters that he eventually ended up at
so remember he was just at this like
atlanta community theater to start he
ended up you know at the acclaimed fox
theater so he like moved his way up and
i think this one play i know i've been
changed um kind of helped unlock some
things for him so that was his start he
started with plays but even then you
know that hundred plus million a lot of
that was in theater tickets i don't know
how much profit he made from that so the
next thing is he basically said okay i
want to do that and that was 100 million
in over 10 years
yes exactly so it's over like a long
period of time that's amazing
and so basically he wanted to create i
think a movie next um and he basically
wanted to create it's called like the
diary of a mad black woman which
is pretty funny and he definitely knows
his audience right so he's definitely
like tailored his career towards um you
know an audience that he understands
really well but when he wanted to create
this he basically
yeah like no one would take him up on it
he's looking for a distributor um and
the only people that will take him up on
it and act as his distributor was
lionsgate but even then lionsgate was
like uh we're not so sure so basically
tyler had to put up half the money he
said look like you know what if if this
is what it takes like i'll put up half
the money um and how much the nice thing
about that i'm not sure how much it was
actually but um the great thing about
that deal which you'll see throughout
every deal he does so the budget by the
way the budget was 5.5 so he put up two
point uh
two point what's that three
nice
so with that deal though he owned and
controlled the content so basically
every deal he's done like he's he's
owning that ip so the lionsgate ceo
basically said like before it was
released like if this makes 20 million
dollars total because yeah like the
budget was like five mil he's like we'll
be really stoked and it did over 20
million in weekend one um and since then
has made over 150 million dollars in
licensing alone that's crazy so like
first of all like i i understand so he
launched the stuff in in the the 90s or
not in the plays in the 90s and 2000s
and
basically like
the black population is i don't know
what 12 of america and so you think like
so you're gonna do a thing dedicated to
only 12
of one group like there's no way that
can be big and he totally proved it
correct because
it's kind of like um in in uh is it ice
where's bjork from iceland so
i think iceland and iceland doesn't have
a lot of people um but bjork is
incredibly famous and i think the reason
is is like iceland had so much pride
that a huge chunk of the icelandic
population was like oh we love bjork
therefore once they start seeing her
succeed they get behind her and they go
bjork is awesome and that's almost what
happens here a little bit and that's
kind of why sometimes it's cool to
appeal to a smaller but more passionate
base than it is to appeal to
the larger percentage
yeah and by the way iceland has a
population of 366 000 people so is it
that small very small i remember i had a
friend on exchange from iceland and she
told me not jokingly
they have a dating app that makes sure
that you are not related to someone that
you are dating because it is such a
small population and hey they made and
bjork sucks sorry if you're a bjork fan
but objectively she she sucks it is not
good music so like it was definitely you
know they say it was like it was the
product go to the marketing good the
icelandic marketing or whatever she's
from it was wonderful because they made
her famous
that's so funny um anyway so that was
his first foray into movies but then he
kept going okay so he's done play then
he's done a movie and now he wants to do
tv okay so he goes and basically he goes
and creates ten episodes first himself
because again he's like i can do this
like i produce to play for ten years i
don't need like to hire a bunch of
people i can do this myself so he
creates ten episodes first he sells it
to one network called cw and they air it
and the ratings are through the roof
people absolutely love it and because of
that it caught the attention of another
network which basically was like hey can
we steal this um and they did and they
struck a deal for 200 million dollars
for him to leave this other network and
he would produce 90 more episodes and
again
he owned the episodes which is kind of
crazy he owned the ip of those episodes
even after that 200 million deal
this deal alone is expected to have made
him
138 million dollars so
his show his earnings
then um you know people still aren't
really paying attention to tyler for
some reason um he continues to make
remember that lionsgate deal that he did
he continues to make movies with them
and over time he makes an 11 film
franchise that's done over a billion in
sales and netted him specifically him
individually over 290 million dollars
because again he always owned the
copyright
and then tyler made one i mean i'm sure
he's made other bets but one really big
bet in 2015 which basically this whole
time he's like an atlanta native right
and he he kind of saw the potential for
the city and so he bought a plot of land
worth 30 000 sorry 30 million dollars at
the times 330 acres and about double the
size of a warner bros warner brothers
lot and he turned it into this like
production
base or where different like uh media
companies could go and film shows so
since then i think like the walking dead
has filmed their black panther um and
part of it is he actually like it wasn't
just him betting on his city he saw that
in 2008 georgia had changed the tax law
so there were certain incentives for
production companies so we saw
these incentives and he said you know
what i think people are different
production companies and i bet maybe
they they could have created those
incentives just for him
well i mean this happened so the law
happened in 2008. he did this in 2015.
so we saw that this was changing and
basically in 2007 before that law 67
million was spent in
or sorry in georgia
and then in 2018 it was 2.9 billion much
thanks to
tyler and his um investment there but
basically because of that then he was
also to he's since signed like 150
million
deal with viacom cbs to run another
suite of episodes and he's just like
kept going in every juncture he's made
sure to own
what he's producing and so now he like
has listen to this he's basically
amassed 22 films dozens of plays and
1200 tv episodes that's what like his
like life work so far plus this like
production base
and he owns much of his work even the
latest 150 million dollar deal i think
he sold it for five years but after
those five years the rights returned to
him i love tyler perry is there a tyler
perry biography out there i would read
that in a heartbeat yeah i think there's
a few go to google tyler perry house
he's got a
this huge spread in outside of atlanta
with a private jet run a runway no one
has that uh that is baller so i was
doing this podcast earlier today with
rob walling and i was talking about how
at hustle con because i've met all these
like successful people and these
billionaires and stuff like that that i
uh i'm like i was like often i'll meet
someone like for example uh like the
founders of casper or something like
that and i'll say to myself
you know you're like
maybe fi you're financially more
successful than i am maybe um and
like your company's definitely bigger
than my company
but i don't think that you're
necessarily like if i i don't think
you're necessarily 20 times or 50 times
more
smart or smarter than i am or however
much bigger i was like
you know like we're in the same ballpark
you might be a little bit or maybe even
i might be a little bit smarter or even
hard-working or something like that the
difference is is that maybe you just
kept at it or there's probably some luck
involved or you um you kind of like
landed on the right idea like you're not
like significantly better than me and
therefore that's why i believe that most
people can accomplish something
interesting of course like it definitely
takes luck and like all this crazy other
stuff to become a billionaire but like
we can all become uh pretty successful
if we just kind of stick with it because
the intelligence isn't that big of a
factor in order to achieve some success
however
i see guys like tyler perry
and i see the work that they like their
output and their genius and i think well
we're just not the same you're just
better than me like you are so good at
what you do
like i went and just i saw hamilton the
other day and i was researching lin
manuel um and i was like oh you're just
a freak like you like like i was
watching it and i was like i don't even
like musicals but the fact that someone
was so brilliant that they came up with
us and put this together that like i
understand you should be a billionaire
like you should have it all you should
or like when i read harry potter i'm
like how on earth does one person invent
this in their brain you you're better
than me you and i we are not the same
you are just a different human being and
you're more of an alien than you are a
human being and that's how i feel about
tyler perry that's how i feel about like
lin emanuel or what's the name lin
manuel
and that's how i feel about like a jk
rowling type so kudos to tyler perry he
deserves it yeah i mean it's crazy he's
done like over 1200 tv episodes like you
have to be just like so good at what you
do to be able to do that for like i
think his first play came out in 1992 so
he's been creating for 30 years straight
and it's like some people are one hit
wonders like this guy is not a one-hit
wonder he like knows what he's doing
he's like honed in his craft and so yeah
it's like super cool i remember i got a
lot of flack for this but i like once
tweeted something about like jeff bezos
i think he had like resigned and i was
like this guy's been working on this
company
for 27 years like how rare is it that
someone works on anything for even like
five years straight and these guys like
tyler perry as well like he's just like
worked on
his craft for decades like that's insane
yeah it's pretty cool i think that um
like we were talking about on this
podcast i was like you know i think i
could become a billionaire if i wanted
to i just you have to be willing to
dedicate like 30 years to it like i'm
definitely smart enough and i and i work
pretty hard um i just don't know if i'm
like if i like want to spend the time
doing it and
and and and i think a lot of people who
achieve greatness they're not much
different except there are people i was
like elon musk and jeff bezos i was like
you just have more horsepower than i do
like you're just different and i'm gonna
put tyler perry in that category you
just you just we're just we're not the
same you know what i mean
yeah i know
it's just like it's like a race car
versus like you know not a race car like
there's just no amount of modifications
can i make my car as fast as that
yeah you have to like have so much
horsepower to want to do this for so
long which is why you're you ask me all
the time you're like you want to be a
billionaire and like every time you ask
me i'm like less sure
of
the fact that i want to do it because
i'm like yeah
everyone wants to be a billionaire
everyone wants to like amass well maybe
not everyone but a lot of people are
like yeah i'd love to live like a great
life but a lot of people don't want to
put in that effort and now i'm
questioning like i think i'll actually
be pretty happy with less than a billion
yes uh i think you'll be
i you do you definitely don't need that
to be happy that's for sure about to see
my first a million got to the safe and
it's filling up got to the bank it's not
big enough